Bộ tình bộ tình bộ tình phản ánh bảo chi về tạm phóan xuất cảnh giòn lợp thế,
phó thu đứng sau bộ tình như tố kỹ bương mắt phát sinh thử tế để sở đợp bộ xung hoàn thiệt quy định
về hoàn thành giế bộ lợp thế trong trường hợp xuất cảnh và đạm lúc quy định và tạo thận lợp trong người nục thế
chính chính phủ chất ngay ai mươi tình sấu. Lên quan đến phản ánh của một số cơ quan bảo chi và mạng sáo hội
về vệ nồi nục thế bị tạm phóan xuất cảnh giòn lợp thế với số tiên nhau.
Bàng nghiệp vụ thuế của thời chế biết vì tạm hỏa xuất cảnh đã được quy định từ lợp quan đi thuế và nghĩ định sống bộ chiến
của định của thành giống ớn áp sộ biển phát tạm hỏa xuất cảnh đối với tình nhau đối tượng.
Cụ thuế chế biết quán sản xuất giữa khoa đi thuế phà lớn các trường hợp phản ánh là càng nhận đã bảo để chỉ kinh suán
không được hiện thu tục thông bảo với các quán đánh kinh suán và cơ quan thuế thế quy định.
Cơ quan thuế đã phối hợp với chính quy định phương để sáng mình xuân nghiệp.
Nguyễn đại diện pháp loại gạy địa chỉ đánh ký.
Đồng thời gửi thông bảo với tình hình lợp thế lên hệ qua số địa thoại ime đả tăng ký với các quán thuế.
Mọi giá chức kỹ áp dụng biển phát tạm hỏa xuất cảnh.
Cơ quan thuế còn tủy thông bảo chức bà mình ngày tựa tạm khoảng thuế địa tựa gửi xuân nghiệp và người đại diện pháp loại.
Thông bảo cũng được gửi tựa điện chỉ cứ chú đánh tý.
Đồng thời thông hai trên cộng thông tin để tựa quán ngành thử.